Hey youtubers it’s charlie since Hannibal
Season 2 is coming up in a couple weeks I
thought it was time to do a preview video
with all the new stuff and things we know
so far.
And Valentine’s Day seemed as appropriate
a time as any since it’s going to be a Friday
show this year.
If you’re a fannibal finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get all
my videos.
I’ll be doing videos for each episode.
There will be 13 just like season 1.
So let’s start this way.
I’ll talk a little about what the characters
are going to be doing and the major changes
from season 1 and then I’ll list all the
episode titles and what meals they correspond
to.
One of the best parts of Hannibal is that
the episode titles are all gourmet meals.
Grab your fork and let’s dig in.
The biggest change from season 1 is obviously
the reversal of Hannibal lecter and will graham.
Will is institutionalized like hannibal will
be eventually and Hannibal has taken will’s
job consulting with the FBI.
Based on the trailer it looks like they’re
not wasting any time in someone else learning
the truth about hannibal being the real serial
killer.
The image of him attacking Lawrence Fishburne
with the knife was one of the first official
images they released.
One of the big issues I had with the trailer
is the idea that it could be unreliable narration.
A lot of last season was spent on whether
or not Will Graham was hallucinating and there
were several times the show did scenes that
turned out to be false memories.
That being said, I don’t think Bryan Fuller
would pull a huge fake out in the trailer,
so I do think that Hannibal will end up trying
to kill Jack Crawford.
Unless they deviate from the original canon,
he’s still alive during Silence of the Lambs,
which takes place chronologically after season
2.
The big theme of the season is Will Graham
coming after Hannibal with a vengeance.
I really love how the show finds ways to mirror
imagery from silence of the lambs.
So it will be like Will graham is anthony
hopkins trying to help the FBI catch Hannibal,
who is kind of like the buffalo bill of this
season.
A lot of the early episodes will deal with
Will getting Alana, Beverly, Abrams and Crawford
to believe in him again.
I have to say though, of all the supporting
characters my favorite aside from Gillian
Anderson, who is just flat out amazing, is
Scott Thompson.
Hugh Dancy said that when they’re on set,
Scott makes them laugh so hard even when they’re
filming the bloodiest of scenes.
Everytime I see him on screen all I can think
about is Kids in the Hall.
One of the best parts of Hannibal I think
is that you know how the story is going to
end.
So Bryan Fuller and the cast delight in allowing
things to unfold in these really fascinating
ways.
Style and cinematography is a huge part of
the show.
Which is a good intro to the episode titles.
I’m just going to do a breakdown of what
the titles are and what they mean.
Everyone open your cook books to page 1.
1 Kaiseki - Is actually a meta term.
It is both a multi course japanese meal and
it refers to the types of skills necessary
to prepare high level cuisines.
This is where things get really interesting.
All of the episode titles this season are
the titles of the different courses of kaiseki.
So think of season 2 as a single meal, with
13 different courses.
Each course of the meal has a different purpose,
texture and taste.
They’ve only released details on 8 of the
13 episodes.
We don’t know anything about episodes 2
or 3, but episode 4 is titled Takiawase - this
course is vegetables served with meat.
Episode 5 is called Mukozuke - this course
is a sliced dish of sashimi.
Bryan fuller posted a picture from the editing
bay of Hannibal swimming.
Episode 6 is Futamono - it’s a soup. and
there’s another behind the scenes picture
of mads in it.
Episode 7 is called Yakimono - It’s flame
broiled fish served in pottery.
Episode 8 is called Su-zakana - it’s a course
that’s meant to be a palate cleanser, like
vegetables in vinegar.
Episode 9 is Shiizakana - this course is a
really big dish served in a hot pot.
It kind of implies something really big is
going to happen.
we don’t know anything about episode 10
but episode 11 is called Kō No Mono - it’s
a dish of pickled vegetables.
and we don’t know anything about the final
two episodes.
Like I said, there are actually 14 different
courses as part of this meta japanese dinner.
So these are the other titles they could use
for those episodes we don’t know about yet.
Sakizuke is the appetizer, so I don’t think
they’ll use this title.
Hassun is the second course, which implies
they’ll use it for episode 2, Hiyahsi Bachi
is only served during the summer and it’s
just another vegetable dish.
Naka - Choko is another palate cleanser.
Gohan is a rice dish, Tome-wan is a miso-based
soup dish and the only other course they haven’t
used as an episode title is Mizumono, the
dessert course.
Like I said, the only one of those titles
I don’t think they’ll use is the appetizer,
Sakizuke.
But as the season gets started I’ll try
to discuss the relevance of each dish to the
story in each episode.
One of the really cool stylistic touches they
add to the show are hannibals literal meals,
which look delicious and make you feel sick
at the same time.
My next hannibal video will be my top 5 moments
from season 1, I’ll post that next friday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it!.
And have a happy valentine’s day, have fun
cooking something or someone tonight.
Right now click here for my game of thrones
foreshadowing breakdown and click here for
my walking dead episode 9 review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!